physikalische revolution wurde jetzt das
tetra neutronen entdeckt seit mehr als
50 jahren suchen wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler nach einem teilchen
das nur aus vier neutronen besteht
physikalisch gesehen allerdings ein
unmögliches zeichen doch jetzt
möglicherweise der durchbruch fachleute
aus münchen wollen dieses unmögliche
tetra neutronen in einem experiment
nachgewiesen haben warum das eine
physikalische revolution ist jetzt in
klicks um science and future hier gibt
es drei mal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's
herzlich willkommen jahrelang gab es
eine hitzige debatte unter den teilchen
physikerinnen und physikern weltweit die
große frage kann es teilchen geben die
nur aus neutronen bestehen den gängigen
physikalischen theorien zufolge ist das
undenkbar schließlich dürfen solche
teilchen die neutronen bestehen nicht
stabil genug sein um zu existiert das
pauli ausschlussprinzip bei dem es um
den aufbau von atom in der quantenphysik
geht beispielsweise lässt die existenz
solcher teilchen gar nicht zu wenn man
sich die atomkerne der elemente anschaut
wird deutlich dass diese normalerweise
aus zwei bausteinen aufgebaut sind zum
einen aus den positiv geladenen protonen
und zum anderen aus den ungeladenen
neutronen die so genannte starke
kernkraft hält sie zusammen und sorgt
dafür dass die elemente relativ stabil
eine ausnahme bilden hier die
radioaktiven elemente wenn neutronen
aber alleine vorkommen zerfallen sie
innerhalb kürzester zeit in einen
elektronen protonen und ein
antineutrinos fast unmöglich wird es
dann wenn man ausschließlich neutronen
zusammen tut den teilchen können im
selben system nicht den gleichen
quantenzustand einem so sagt ist dass
pauli ausschlussprinzip doch bei einem
teilchen aus zwei drei oder vier
gruppierten neutronen wäre ja genau das
der fall physikalisch gesehen ist die
existenz eines solchen chatrooms also
schlicht unmöglich doch es gibt auch
argumente die für die existenz von
solchen teilchen sprechen die
neutronensterne nämlich in ihrem zentrum
sind mehrere hundert millionen tonnen
auf einem kubikzentimeter
zusammengepresst solche neutronensterne
konnten so schnell rotieren dass sie pro
sekunde mehrere 100 umdrehungen schaffen
es handelt sich um die extremste materie
form im universum diese wenige kilometer
großen aber enorm dichten sternen rest
die entstehen wenn ein massereicher
stern am ende seines lebenszyklus
kollabiert die existenz dieser
neutronensterne zeigt ebenfalls dass es
offensichtlich sehr wohl objekte geben
kann die aus neutronen bestehen die
dicht aneinander gepackt sind und so
suchen wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler seit mehr als 50 jahren
nach einem teilchen das aus zwei drei
oder sogar vier neutronen besteht und
jetzt endlich der durchbruch ein
münchner forschungsteam bricht jetzt in
einer aktuellen studie dass der nachweis
gelungen ist in einem experiment konnte
die existenz eines teilchens bewiesen
werden dass aus vier neutronen besteht
sein name tetra matronen wie kann man
sich dieses teilchen vorstellt wie wurde
es aufgespürt und was bedeutet das für
die theoretischen physik die spannenden
antworten auf all diese fragen gibt es
bei pixum science und wirtschaft der
streit um das tetra neutronen sorgt
schon seit jahren immer mal wieder für
hitzige debatten in der fachwelt schon
im jahr 2002 gab es erste hinweise auf
ein solches mögliches zeichen aus vier
neutronen ein französischer
beschleuniger versuch kam zu einem
wirklich erstaunlichen ergebnis
beryllium 14 kerne wurden dabei auf
kohlenstoff geschossen doch statt vier
einzel neutronen konnten signale
gemessen werden die für ein teilchen aus
vier verbundenen neutronen sprachen
andere wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler konnten das experiment
mitsamt dem überraschenden ergebnis
nicht nachvollziehen und das ganze wurde
als fehler abgehakt vor fünf jahren
wollte ein japanisches experiment neue
indizien für dieses eigentlich
unmögliche teilchen geliefert haben
zumindest indirekt wollten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
damals ein solches textarten
nachgewiesen haben ihre simulation
hatten nahegelegt dass solche neutronen
klumpen möglicherweise durch einen
resonanz effekt möglich werden fachleute
des ricken forschungszentrums in japan
hatten die vier kerne mit helium acht
kernen im beschleuniger kollidieren
lassen eigentlich entstehen bei diesem
experiment zwei helium 4 kerne und vier
einzelner thron doch die sind vier
neutronen wurden nicht durch den
detektor registriert dafür aber eine
andere überraschung die rede ist von
einer wirklich winzigen pause die 18 uhr
zehntelsekunden an hielt danach tauchten
dann zerfallsprodukte von neutronen auf
nicht aber die vermissten neutronen
selbst die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler nahmen damals die
energiebilanzen genauer ins visier so
kamen sie dann an den indirekten
nachweis des tetra neutronen dass sich
innerhalb der pause durch die 40 thron
gebildet haben muss in dieser studie war
die rede von immerhin 4 90 mal und damit
erreicht er das ergebnis fast den status
einer entdeckung in der teilchenphysik
gilt eine signifikanz von 5 als
entdeckung und das verlangt eine
wahrscheinlichkeit von
99,9999 prozent russischen simulationen
haben supercomputer bekräftigten dieses
ergebnis denn auch hier wurde klar das
tetra neutronen physikalisch doch
möglich sind wenn auch nur für thriller
sekunden eine art resonanz effekt könnte
das möglich machen durch den das pauli
prinzip für bruchteile von sekunden
verletzt auch die münchner
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
hatten es jetzt auf das tetra neutronen
abgesehen ein strahl stark beschleunigt
der lithium atomkerne wurde dabei auf
ein ziel aus kohlenstoff und lithium
oxid geschossen lizum isotope und dabei
als erzeugungs helfer eingesetzt wenn
bei den lithium atomkern handelt es sich
um das isotop lithium 7 dieses besteht
aus drei protonen und 49
dazu heißt es in der studie lithium 7
ist der dem thron am nächsten stehende
stabile atom nur drei protonen müssen
dem lithium 7 entzogen werden um daraus
ein teilchen aus vier neutronen zu
produzieren und genau das war ja das
ziel der fachleute dafür nutzen sie den
tandem bahn der graf beschleuniger der
tu münchen die zum 7 teilchen wurden auf
etwa zwölf prozent der
lichtgeschwindigkeit beschleunigt und
dann auf das sie zum sieben tage
geschossen genau hierbei sollte dann
nicht nur kohlenstoff 10 entstehen
sondern eben auch das eigentlich
unmögliche tetra neutronen so zumindest
die theoretischen überlegungen der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
und tatsächlich der nachweis dieser
seltenen spezies gelangen und zwar
ebenfalls
auch in einer wiederholung des
experiments konkreten namen die
fachleute die energien und massen der
teilchen genauer ins visier die durch
die kollision entstand nur hier
entdeckten sie einen kuriosen buckel in
der kurve bei 20,8 mega elektronenvolt
dieser peak ist nicht mit der existenz
von gängigen teilchen zu erklären aber
sehr wohl mit der entstehung von tetra
neutronen und angeregten kohlenstoff 10
isotopen dazu sagt der physiker thomas
westermann der an der studie beteiligt
war das ist für uns die einzige
physikalische in allen punkten quasi
viele erklärungen gemessen werden die
forschenden ermittelten dabei eine
bindungsenergie des teams von 0,42 mega
elektronenvolt ein wert der gut mit
theoretisch ermittelten werten überein
stimmt demnach wäre das ungefähr so
stabil wie das neutron selbst danach
würde es mit einer halbwertszeit von 450
sekunden durch beta zerfall den
fachleuten selbst ist klar dass sie
damit lediglich einen indirekten
nachweis des täters erreicht haben
ausgerechnet haben sie dass sie das
tetra neutronen mit einer
wahrscheinlichkeit von 99,7 entdeckt
haben eine gesicherte entdeckung ist es
demnach also nicht denn davon ist in der
wissenschaftler erst eine
wahrscheinlichkeit von
99,9999 prozent die rede heißt also im
klartext die messung müssten weiter
präzisiert werden außerdem auch durch
andere wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler überprüft werden auf der
anderen seite ist dieses ergebnis aus
münchen wenn nicht der erste hinweis auf
die existenz des tetra neutrons hier
zeigt sich mal wieder wie mühselig
assist neue teilchen zu entdecken auch
die entdeckung des berühmten higgs
teilchens ging ja nicht von jetzt auf
gleich auch hier waren ja lange
messungen und analysen notwendig da
steht also dass die fahndung nach dem
täter neutronen weitergeht wenn auch
andere experimente und forschungsgruppen
die hinweise bestätigen können muss das
pauli ausschlussprinzip umgeschrieben
werden eine art physikalische revolution
wenn die existenz der tetra neutronen
dann final bestätigt werden kann könnte
dies auch erklären wie neutronensterne
zustande kommen denn bis heute zu gelten
diese als große rätsel der astrophysik
erstmals im experiment bestätigt eichen
sind welle und teilchen zugleich und es
kann beeinflusst werden super spannendes
video also anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren das geht ganz einfach mit dem
button den ist unter jedem video gibt
also bis dann bleibt dran